(walkie-talkie)
(langue étrangère)
- La maison d'Oleksandr et
de Lyudmila n'est pas si loin,
une quinzaine de kilomètres
représente aujourd'hui un long
périple parsemé d'embûches :
des points de contrôle,
et des cet des cet des carcasses
calcinés, autant de vestiges
se sont déroulés ici.
est en bonne partie détruit.
Mais un
revenu depuis que les soldats
russes se sont retirés.
en profitent pour revenir voir
leur maison.
Aussitôt accueillis par
Rejik, le chien des voisins,
Un soulagement.
- Ah!
est en piètre état.
"Voilà, dit-il,
ressemble la paix russe."
Un obus, tombé dans le jardin,
a ravagé la façade
Les dommages sont importants.
"C'est un cauchemar,
Ce qu'ils ont fait
horrible."notre terrnotre terrne
mère patrie, pré
et personne ne va nous forcer à
"Nous sommes fort
ajoute Lyudmila, et personne
si unis que Vladimir Poutine
lui-même. Personne."
le fruit de 40 ans de dur
labeur.
"Regardez les impacts
de balles, dit-elle. C'est
Comme beaucoup dans la région
de Kharkiv, Oleksandr et
Et ils ne supportent pas
d'avoir servi de prétexte
pour cette invasion.
"C'est comme ça : les supposés
soldats de la paix russes sont
apparemment venus nous libérdit.
Mais de tement?"ant, le coant, d
des nouvelles des
ceux qui sont restés sur place,
pendant toute l'occupation.
Pas question pour lui de partir,
roquette tombée dadin.din.din.d.
c'est tombé là, dit-il.
Moi, je n'ai rien demandé.
Le vieil homme se sait miraculé
et en entendant la visite des
démineurs, il a juré de rester.
Il se sent d'ailleurs
bien plus en sécurité
depuis que les soldats russes
ont quitté les villes et
les villages situés au nord'est.
Et la r laquelle
la situation est un petit peu
c'est que les forces
ukrainiennes sont en train de
mener depuis plusieurs semaines
contre les soldats russes.On voi
la préparation d'une de
pour effet de repousser
les Russes, parfoi
jusqu'à la frontière avec
leur pays, donc de desserrer
de Kharkiv qui est presque
maintenarement hors de
portée de l'artillerie russe.
(tirs)
Cette unité spéciale de l'armée,
"brouillard", et ces hommes
leur fierté, car le terrainrecos
grands sacrifices, est d'une
Le commandant de l'unité se fait
appeler "kran", et il reconnaît
que les
plus nombreux et mieux équipés,
mais il affirme que ses hommes
sont plu
qu'ils connaissent bien mieux
le terrain.
c'est notre moral et notre
détermination sans faille",
"C'est notre terre.
Nous protégeons notre mère
patrie, nos enfants,il.il.il.il.
Il n'y a pas de meilleure
motivation."
Orest, son bras dène au buène ,
pour nous montrer
récupérées des combattants
russes en déroute.
"Ce sont nos trophées, dit-il.,
comme ce Dragunov,
Il nous montre aussi un autre
cadeau, beaucoup plus utile
un NLAW,
britannique, qui a permis de
russes. Il en profite pour
lancer un appel aux pays
"Il est évident que nous avons
Nos hommes sont motivés, mais
nous manquons d'équipements
spécialisés, des lunettes deoct"
Cette a
le seul moyen de terminer
donc, de limiter les pertes
en vies humaines.
Une guerre dont Oleksandr et
avec impatience...
... se promettant mutuellementdi